hi president Trump's laser focused on
cracking down on illegal immigration I'm
sure you've heard that before
it was a hallmark of his campaign making
America safe again in fact border
crossings are down yet a new report
suggests he sent fewer Mexicans back to
their country between January and
December of this year compared to
President Obama did during the same time
in 2016 now President Trump as you know
is working hard at keeping Mexicans from
crossing over illegally in the first
place he hinted last week he'll make a
trip soon to our southern border over to
San Diego to look at prototypes for his
proposed wall he's going to ultimately
make the choice they're gonna be about
30 feet high and then we'll see if
they're going to do something below
because we've got a little tunnel
problem
Kennedy yes what is it what does this
study say to you that we've actually had
less Mexican apprehensions in 2017 and
2012 also had fewer illegal border
crossings so the president did some very
good messaging it was very effective
good marketing when he was running for
president in that you know fewer people
came into this country illegally and
also it shows that the president has a
much bigger heart than President Obama
who was absolutely awful about deporting
people and ripping families apart and
it's it's laughable that he reached out
to the Latino community the way he did
because he was incredibly heartless with
his deportations and President Trump is
actually softened there and looked for
other ways to try and solve the
immigration crises we face in this
country Murray it turns out the I had a
chance got out of the border two weeks
ago and they do think the beginning of
the wall be built in the Rio Grande
Valley sector area where it is indeed
the worst but the word came out in the
first half of the year that we were
cracking down and it slowed down in the
second half of the year we didn't do
anything policy wise because Congress
couldn't get their act together it
picked up again and then you have these
numbers overall what does it tell you
well I think we will see how big
president Trump's heart is as we deal
with daca in the new year I mean as we
look at 2018 that's the biggest
immigration fight we're going to have I
think pretty early on the numbers are
interesting I'm not sure exactly what to
make of them I think fewer people are
coming here they've arrested more
immigrants but they have deported fewer
back to Mexico so
I think we'll see when it comes to the
wall though I do not predict the
President Trump will be able to build a
wall across the entire border I think he
will find places where he can put up a
structure so he can go take a photo with
it say he's kept his promise because of
some of these places I think the
landowners aren't gonna want to aren't
going to want to give up their land
you know they very much don't want the
government coming in in some of these
places and taking their land to build a
wall or some kind of main battle exactly
this is going to be an eminent tornado
main battle yeah did I don't think
everyone is is focused on it on a wall
wall up there I mean they don't want
people illegal cross property where is
it but if you go back the Texas
especially this is an issue because
there are families who were actually
property owners on land before Texas
became a state and part of the United
States of America and so there are the
culture there is a little bit different
and there's a deal with the issue
however that does not mean that they
don't want border security that they
don't want Border Patrol to be on their
property working with border patrol to
make sure that people aren't crossing
back and forth but that doesn't
necessarily mean they want their ranches
divided right by a big wall so there is
going to be a very big battle there in
terms of the numbers you know not all
illegal immigrants in this country are
Mexicans in fact only 50% of them are
the rest are other than Mexican and one
of the big problems that we have too is
visa overstays there are 54 million
people who come into the country every
year 700,000 of them tend to stay behind
interior enforcement is an issue and
under Obama he was called the DePorter
in chief but the way that they measured
that number was they've catch people at
the border and immediately deport them
and they counted that as a deportation
that's not going into communities and
rounding people up and deporting them
they were counting people coming across
turning themselves into Border Patrol
and then getting kicked back out as a
deportation and that's why that number
was so high
that's a great point and I think this
Tom one thing is key also clear it's not
just Mexicans in fact Central America
and South America depending on where the
poorest areas are Mexico's going yeah
you can keep going if you can come in as
we don't wanted to say there I keep so
it's really not Mexico right now that is
the problem that's the sense among the
border control patrol but keep in mind
to the fear of drugs fentanyl in
particular coming across our southern
border is very real they think that is
picking up - yeah well the fact that
you have fewer people being deported
should be celebrated the headlines in
the paper
Trump sends home fewer Mexicans despite
deportation talk another headline Donald
Trump reporting fewer people and then it
says rhetoric versus realities if he was
just targeting Mexicans for deportation
yes in the fact that it's empty talk
it's not empty talk about if your tough
talk makes fewer people come across the
border the headlines should be Trump
immigration policy working right no
absolutely the other thing that they're
working on I believe it's gonna happen
in January Kennedy they're gonna start
talking about if they're gonna come
together and anything it's going to be
immigration evidently there's a
bipartisan committee in the Senate
meeting right now that are going to
attacking chain migration because I
believe there's sentiment on both sides
to attack it the lottery as well and
daca you mix it in with border security
could this be our first joint
legislation since the early 20s yeah
it's interesting because people's
feelings about immigration tend to
evolve with some of the facts reality
and news that happens and you know
whether it's Kate Steinle death which
certainly galvanized on the right or
some of the terror incidents which you
know reach across party lines and people
start to go well I'm wondering about the
kind of people that are in my community
and how do we keep the country safer
while still attracting the very best
people in the world to come and work it
businesses and help take care of
families and participate in the economy
I mean that's ultimately what you want
so the question is how do we fix
immigration to keep bad people out
without compromising our civil liberties
and and that that's a big goal it's the
ultimate goal but I think actually
Republicans and Democrats are much
closer on that because people
essentially want the same thing they
want the country to be safe they want
the best and brightest people here and
they realize that the system is broken
on several ends you know visas and visa
overstays that Katie talked about we
have to fix the visa system and
Democrats have to live up to the
promises that they made on border
security 11 years ago Marie tell me
where the no-go zone is and I believe I
have not heard it yet except for build
the wall which Senator Schumer does not
want to give President Trump this
victory he might give in but I have not
heard him object to chain migration and
the lottery system being re-examined
saying daca of course the president said
listen I'm kind of in fact getting this
done by March
so do you do you think that they're
actually weak might be two-thirds of the
way there or am I dreaming no I think we
actually you're wide awake you're not
totally dreaming I think we might be
close Jeff Flake tweeted that he that
there will be a doc a bipartisan bill
come to the Senate floor after the New
Year I think that that was something he
got in exchange for being a YES on tax
reform or as part of a conversation
Chuck Schumer was part of the gang of
eight who talked about ending chain
migration this is something that
Democrats are absolutely open to talking
about if that's the package that gets
put together earlier in the new year is
the closer you get to November the
harder it becomes right if we can do
that I absolutely think we can get a bye
tonight I think she's right I think if
you are able to tackle daca and the
dreamers yes and take care of things
like gee migration in the lottery system
and you you don't fold amnesty into
absolutely then that's going to be a
really big challenge because the details
of daca are going to be hard to work out
what is the threshold in terms of the
the timing for ready were brought here
and do you get to stay
sixty-six percent of the immigrant the
illegal immigrants in this country have
been here for more than ten years which
means the rest of them have only been
here for five that's a lot of people who
are going to be looking for some kind of
form of amnesty and it ultimately
doesn't solve the question of what do we
do with people who are here because
they're not all dreamers and let's not
forget that Barack Obama's dream or
policy caused an influx of unaccompanied
minors cause a huge crisis and that is a
potential to happen again if they aren't
careful about the way that they debate
the legislation time you're in a tough
spot because you were gonna use chain
migration to bring more shalu's across
the border and this trend against you
Bay what happened to the other shalu's
she'll is gonna do just fine because
they they they do have merits okay yeah
you bring something to the use Jane
Michael we don't need chain migration
right the solutes can come here because
they're highly skilled all right fine
Jim at the criteria yes and plus you can
sing and dance that absolutely true I
think I think it's true in the big
picture this is the one thing I fear
because I think we're all tired of this
conservatives will say you better not do
a deal on daca and Democrats said you
can't do a deal with Trump we got the
Republicans on their back if you bring
that if you had Trump stand up and look
like a consolidator they do think there
goes the midterm election we need I
think we're confident enough in what
we're running on we need Daka and
actually the Kennedys point the fact
that we're so many Republicans have come
out in support of daca and getting it
fixed and done is not alone but no no no
not alone but is it's such a sea change
from where we were even a year ago two
years ago three years ago that's why I
think this is gonna get this done he's
eight hundred thousand dreamers I do
think both sides of the aisle want to
find a compromise they don't all get
kicked out I just say though that the
illegal immigration system in this
country is also severely broken yes
illegal right and I believe it is unfair
that we are focusing on the illegal
immigration reform of this problem be
sure we are focusing on the legal reform
because people wait 5 10 15 years to
come to this country legally yeah
because a thousands of dollars right and
they're currently using the fees that
the legal immigrants are paying for daca
and the dreamers that were here before
that is the money that was used under
Obama that's how he got away with doing
it and not going through Congress and so
I do think we have to rethink our
priorities daca is one that a lot of
people can agree on but there are bigger
immigration problems putting Americans
first that the president campaigned on
that I think should be kept first I'm a
part of the soccer community which is
prides itself on internationals and they
are kind of angry at the whole talk of
daca because they go through the green
card say for the most part they'll say
wait a second what about us but there's
a difference and this is where I give
people credit for having a more subtle
and nuanced conversation about
immigration because they realize it's
really heartless to deport people if
this is the only home they've ever known
and that's that's the basis for the
argument for protecting dreamers right
but also at the same time having said
that then you don't create the influx
you kind of close the door and that's
when you fix the immigration system and
I don't think you shut down the number
of visas I think you do a better job of
vetting people and allow people in who
are going to who are good people who are
going to work hard what is the metric
for that how do you vet for that I don't
know I don't know if anyone has the
answer
another big question to you look at
docker in the dreamers right we talked
about not breaking up families well
guess what dreamers all have families
and if their parents are illegal
immigrants which many of them are
because ice has delivered children to
their parents in this country been
living here illegally for years what do
you do with their family do they
automatically get amnesty do they get to
stay what is their status and so that's
a very tough question because you can
argue if you pass through daca the
entire family by default gets to stay
because we're not a heartless country
that Deportes and breaks up families and
that is something difficult to to deal
with you guys know what I'm doing right
now what I'm crossing at the a block we
have just done it done and all the
pressure doing such a good teacher thank
you very much and all the pressure is
about to go in your shoulders young lady
to match that okay